medicines are designed and they are
prescribed and administered to treat
ailments pregnancy is not an illness a
baby is not a disease we might treat the
baby like a like a cancerous tumor but
the baby is not a cancerous tumor the
baby is a baby again there's no way
around this it is not medicine pregnancy
is not an ailment it is not something to
treat and get rid of like a disease now
we should treat we we provide treatment
to pregnant women to facilitate their
pregnancy and to deal with problems that
come up during the pregnancy but the
pregnancy itself is not an ailment it
might be um inconvenient but an
inconvenience is not a sickness